L'Europe dont nous rêvons,
elle ne veut,
elle ne doit plus se construire contre nous,
elle doit se construire avec nous.
Et notre Europe,
c'est celle qui parle de coopération,
d'intérêt mutuel
plutôt que de dumping social,
de compétition forcenée érigée en véritable totem.
Notre Europe,
c'est celle qui respecte les peuples d'abord
plutôt que celle qui les met en concurrence entre eux.
C'est aussi celle qui travaille à la paix et à la
sécurité de tous.
Car nous, voulons-nous, voulons-nous 1 avenir
sûr pour nos enfants ?
La liste de conduite par Léon des fontaines,
elle est composée de femmes et d'hommes
qui ne vivent pas de dividende
mais de leur salaire et de leur engagement
ici. Ce qu'ils ont, c'est pas 1 portefeuille,
c'est leur cœur.
Et c'est avec ce cœur-là
qu'ils vont demain défendre nos droits à Bruxelles.